the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I promised I would play through
the second half of the tournament that I
started last time so two times ago but
before Jennifer Shahi days guest lecture
but before I start so so remember last
time we got to the final table this is
essentially the start of the final table
and but before I get into the hands I
want to do a bit of Theory first that
I've sort of been for going so far in
this class and it's essentially is what
what's called the independent chip model
or ICM theory and essentially what it's
used for is in tournaments essentially
the the value of chips is essentially
nonlinear because you're not really
trying to just get out the chips you're
trying to last as long as possible and
move up the pants so I want to sort of
now formally quantify what this means
and how we calculate the DV of your
Gamble's so far I think I've just told
you you know everything I've done so far
in this class has been shifty B and that
told you you know just play you maximize
chip evey maximize your expected number
of chips and that's a pretty reasonable
way to play and cash games is what you
want to do and in tournaments it's it's
not a bad approximation so I don't want
everyone after this I see I'm not sure
do you think you know I got a completely
change by playing in tournaments because
that's not the case essentially playing
you're maximized expected number of
chips is a pretty good approximation of
how you actually should be playing but
there are some small differences and
extreme situations and I'd like to
highlight some of that today so okay
yeah so this is essentially yes so it's
this idea of minimizing risks you stay
alive and move up to escalating payouts
so I want to make an important
distinction though what I'm saying we're
still trading maximize our expected
amount of money what I'm saying you
should be minimizing your risk in a
tournament so that you can move up the
payouts that is that's different than
saying you should you should minimize
your monetary risk because I'm still
assuming returning maximize our expected
money without worrying about risk but
I'm only minimizing tournament risk to
maximize our expected amount of money
but I'm not saying we should be overly
conservative in
tournament and just trying to move up
the money ladder slowly when you should
be gambling because it's positive money
expectation if you find yourself in this
situation then you know if you're trying
to play like professionally and just
maximize your expected amount of money
in every situation then you should
probably play smaller tournaments where
this is not really the key what if this
doesn't occur to you often you know I
can understand in practice like if you
play poker for fun and you made it farm
in front of it and you know it's like
the top like let's say 50k and there's
like 55 left you know I can understand
why you might not want to make a
positive money X a positive money
expectation play because you know you've
knew you've played this tournament
you're probably not going to be in the
situation that many times in your
lifetime and you just really want to
cash like the World Series of Poker Main
Event or something and I think you know
that's that's a reasonable life decision
I'm not criticizing that decision but
I'm just saying but I'm gonna talk about
all these decisions assuming work we
don't care about that we're still trying
to maximize expected amount of money and
if you aren't playing like
professionally where you're getting into
that situation very frequently then it
is very important to maximize risk in
some cases and to maximize your doll or
evey because you know in tournaments
you're losing most of the time you
really have to win a lot the times that
we do win you can't be content like you
can't be content because we made like
$30,000 that we could have made like
fifty thousand dollars so okay so what
is the exact formula from ICM so I'm
just going to sort of demonstrate how to
calculate the value chips in a
tournament with an example so ICM is
essentially a formula to calculate how
much your stack is worth in a tournament
so let's suppose there's three players
left and the payoffs are five three two
this is a common structure and likes it
and goes if you play those which are
like ten player tournaments so the
statement is essentially your chances of
winning the tournament is proportional
to your percent of the total chips and
essentially we're assuming this champion
is true and we're going to derive from
it all the formulas
and this thing that is a proximal nature
you know there are more advanced ICM
calculators that also take into account
your position if the stack sizes are
rather shallow because there are some
inaccuracies because this statement it
calculates only based on chips but you
know if you're folding and then you're
the button the next hand which is the
best position then that's actually sort
of an entire big blind better almost
then being under together the next but
look more we're not going to worry about
that we're just going to assume you're
aware of chances of winning the
tournament is proportional to your
percentage chips so how do we calculate
this so I sent it so okay so you can't
really do it by hand in practice but for
this example with three people
I'll show you how to do it by hand so
let's suppose the chip stamps are also
five three two okay so the payouts are
five three two and the chip stacks are
also five three two ratio so you know if
should be the equals money evie then the
guy with five thousand their equity from
the tournament should be five dollars
and the guy in third place their equity
should be two dollars right but this is
clearly not correct right
because the guy in third place is
guaranteed two dollars and clearly
there's a nonzero chance of them laying
the tournament so clearly their equity
is actually more than two dollars right
and then similarly if your player a your
equity is clearly not five dollars
because you're not guaranteed to win
they turn up right so it's clear from
this example why if you just do chippy
be equal people's money easy that's
clearly wrong raise equity everyone so
how do we calculate it it's okay so this
is so let's calculate it for player to
see so essentially what it's saying your
chances of winning your chances are
coming first is 2,000 over 10,000 which
is 20% and then you calculate their
chances of coming second you just
condition on each of the other players
way so conditioned on a winning which
will happen 50% of the time we assume
that our chances of coming second is
2,000 divided by 5,000 which is the
remaining number of chips
besides clutter a does that make sense
so player a has 5,000 chips so between
between use player C and player D you've
got five deuce 5,000 ships in total and
you've got 2,000 of those
so it's 2,000 over 5,000 so it's point
four and then if player B wins then your
chances of coming second is 2,000 over
7,000 so overall your chances are coming
second is 0.42 so point is so yeah so
it's just 50% times 0.4 plus 30% times
2/7 which equals 2/7 so then you can
calculate your equity is they're
guaranteed to bucks and you have a 20%
chance of winning which will give you
three additional dollars and then a 29%
chance of coming second which will give
you an additional dollar so your equity
is actually 289 this displace this case
it's actually closer to second place
then third place does I have a place you
make sense to everyone
so if there is like five players you
know you just have to recursively
condition you have to condition on play
a winning and then go through all the
possibilities if you becomes second then
go through all the possibilities if you
becomes third etc etc so it's not a
completion make them really do in your
head it's but there that it's quite easy
to find a calculator to do it for you on
you just Google ICM calculator and you
punch it in and and even though you know
it's not like like your grows
exponentially but you know there's only
going to be like nine players so it's
still fine and we'll take that though
the computer can do it instantly even
for nine ten players okay so what are
some cases where ICM is easy to
calculate so like I said in cash games
there is no such thing as I see em
you're just playing to maximize expected
number of chips and your goal is
essentially you're sitting down at the
cash game looking to get into all and
looking to get into favorable and
hopefully winning the the person who
you're targeting is light and turn and
and winner takes all tournaments it's
also the same the yours because you're
just looking at your chances of winning
the tournament and that's always just
your number of chips so you're just
trying to maximize expected number of
chips so as a corollary once it gets
down to two players there's no knows
more such thing as I see em so sort of
three is the minimum number of players
you need for ICM to be relevant once
it's two players it doesn't maximize
your chip maybe because there's there's
no sense of you know trying to survive
who said someone else busts first
because with only two people for the
other guy bus do you have to you have to
take all their chips okay so what are
some mathematical qualities of the LCM
formula so big sacks have money easy
less than ship TV small snacks have
money you need greater than ship TV
small sex also tend to have positive
shitty B in general this is something I
didn't mention too much but in general
so you might have seen this if you guys
have like Bindu casino and play cash
games so like let's say you sit down at
a table with in a cash game and evarin
buys it for like a hundred big blinds at
some tables usually they'll allow you to
buy in for as low as like 20 big blinds
and if you do this in general that's
gonna be positive
evie for the guy with 20 big blinds
because there's situations where they
have to wear like let's say they have to
essentially sometimes one guy will raise
one guy will call and then you can go on
and then one guy will like go all in on
top of you and the other guy will fold
and then you'll have like good money so
another thing is early on in the
tournament ICM is irrelevant you just
want to can relate chips so like if you
you know if you try to do this formula
early on in a tournament what you'll
find is essentially the essentially
you're so far away from the money that
none of the things really matter to
maximize your chances of even getting
through the money you just wanna
maximize your number of chairs so where
does I see a most relevant it's most
relevant on the exact pay level and on
the final table so let me so roughly
speaking in every took poker tournament
I've seen other than like strange ones
that are like winter takes all our
satellites the pay looks roughly like
this so so it's zero you go in and once
you hit about top twenty percent is the
bubble and then there's like a jump here
or suddenly you get paid so this is
about this is about 80 percent get zero
and then so here there's a jump and then
it escalates slowly until you get to the
final table
[Applause]
final survey is my sister she's color
I know table and then it escalates
really fast so essentially basically I
see them as most relevant at the points
where like essentially the derivative or
the rate of change of the payout is
highest and those points as you can see
are here and here so essentially it
matters most at the exact money bubble
and in the final table okay let me clear
this okay so yeah so some more extreme
examples of ICM is you have one ship let
left late in a tournament when everyone
else has thousands of chips
so clearly this ship is worth a lot more
than its value as a fraction of the
chips and your is trying to survive with
this one chip essentially instead of
trying to win more chips and and so
maybe maybe I was talking about this in
a bit so in satellites so sad what
satellites are there tournaments where
you're trying to qualify for a bigger
tournament so essentially the important
thing is so you know there will be maybe
like a hundred players and there will be
ten seats which means the top ten get an
invite to the bigger tournament and then
everyone else gets nothing so answer the
qualifiers for the MIT Series of Poker
Main Event are kind of like this right
it says your eternity
I guess there's other prizes too but
you're essentially trying to come to
Talk 10 so this is how that works and in
that case right the pay though is the
payout is essentially this so there's
not really much incentive to win you're
just trying to be one of this top 10%
that gets paid so that's another case
where ICM has extreme importance and you
often find you are not often but you can
often make a case for folding pocket
aces pretty fun even though it's even
though you know it's gonna have positive
chip TV if you call because it's the
best possible hand but because you just
really don't want to bust then you
actually want to fold theses okay we'll
talk about this a bit more later later
or less get to okay so let's get back to
the tournament so this is the final
table so ICM is going to be quite
relevant here and so I as I'm talking
through my decisions in the hands I'll
talk about sort of the ICM decisions as
well okay so this is a
this is the first hand or I think might
have maybe one orbit past but so we're
at the final table we're right now we're
the second biggest stack and so yeah we
should maybe look at the stack sizes so
we look around at the stack sizes so so
what do you notice about this access or
like specifically like how are we doing
how many just how many chips we have
we'll right we have quite a lot right we
have quite a lot but we're not in the
first place there's this one guy who
covers us so this pen hand Krissy guy uh
if you covers us so specifically the
thing I'm trying to avoid is getting in
a big pot with Pam and Chrissy like I
mean let's say she goes all in and I
have pocket kings I'm gonna call but I'm
not going to be that happy about calling
in a situation where otherwise I should
be very happy just because you know
chances are he's gonna have an ace he's
gonna have 30% equity I mean it's no
gonna be positive money you need to call
but it's so bad if I basically bust
right now in eighth place against the
damn hangers so essentially I'm really
incentivized to avoid like getting in
big pots of them and I'm essentially
hoping for some of these smaller stacks
to bust so that then even if I lose a
big pot to him I don't get the low
eighth place payoff so okay so it's
folded to us we raise here I think this
is one of the weakest hands I I'm
raising from the button but so far
players have seemed to be reasonably
tight so I'm gonna raise and then I get
the blinds
okay so I'll supposed to give some hands
at the beginning near the end they'll
apply every hand this thing we don't
play but I'll try to show the hands were
someone busts so this hand small one
goes all in big blind calls and so small
mine wins with ten to suited against ace
4 which is basically great for everyone
because someone busted
you're always cheering for people to
bust especially and I think also both of
their plays are fine so I think small
with small minds play it looks a bit
silly but realistically not only does 10
-
reasonable equity when you're called
it's also the ICM is very very very
developed like this Gerard ox died he's
not the shortest I mean he is one of the
shortest so he does need to take some
risk but he's still really very much
would like to bust after I show to hit
78 so he so he can't call with anything
I mean with ace floor I think that's
definitely good enough to call but let's
say they have like king two officers I
think that's a situation I do normally
call if it was like not a final table
under tournament but I had a final table
where I'm not the shortest and there's
someone shorter than me
I would consider folding tend to cert
King to offsuit here just because um
just because of ICM essentially all
right so the next hand so so the so the
big blind busts and then there's no
small line this sandwich is great
because where people are less than sent
device of steel and indeed we get our
nice it's not much happens here I'll
skip forward a bit okay this hand I
guess it's quite convenient for us but
this'll illustrate the points so okay so
so this guy who doesn't love a bit
earlier right now he goes on and for
quite a lot right this is quite a big
shove and if you plenty by my
recommendations I would never recommend
shoving like this this many bets I mean
it's not it's like 24 it's quite great
actually 23 it says 23 23 big blinds
which is like wage you watch the show
right there's no need you can't risk
this much but once again I think his
play is justifiable because of ICM you
know he doesn't and so ok so let's see
what he had so we call I mean here it's
a bit different because even if I call
and lose I'm not out of the tournament
and I mean even if I even if I'm what
would be out like even if you have to
mm I'd probably still call with Queens
mr. beautiful so we need a screen here
which is great for us but if you look at
the play from his perspective again it
actually seems quite reasonable if you
think about it because you know for him
ace queen is a great hand from this
position it's definitely good enough
where you know if it was between folding
and shoving for 23 big blinds you would
definitely rather rather show for 23 big
blinds so you know the main reason why
normally one would criticize his play is
because you know why that wasn't he just
made a small with ace Queen well
understandably he doesn't really want
you want to incentivize me to like
rebates or panca see to make a tree
raise he actually wants to minimize the
chances that he actually played for his
stack in this hand and the way he does
that is essentially by going all-in
so if so you know looking looking at
back at it I think his play is fine the
only weakness of his play I think is it
is a bit sort of predictable what his
hand is in this situation because I
think like if he had a hand as good as
pocket aces then he shouldn't be doing
this he should just be raising small
because it's good enough where he's
happy getting it in against me or
pan-pan chrissie where is you know also
if his hand was slightly worse like East
Jack offsuit I think is a good example I
think ace Jack offsuit is is not strong
enough to make this all and play with
but you still want to be raising so I
think there's a small range of hands
that you want to be making this on plays
like I think that's basically exactly
ace Queen off suit maybe Ace King maybe
ace Queen Ace King and then like middle
pairs let's say like between like
pockets eights and pocket tennis or
something so so like the only downside
of this play I think is essentially his
range here is very predictable it's
gonna be like ace Jack suited plus ace
queen and pocket eights three times or
something like that so but nonetheless I
mean I think because it's a final table
because if I see em it's fine
he gets unlucky nobody runs into Queens
here we get a walk okay so let's see
this hand so I show two raises goes
all-in so we call here we're kind of
deep
where I want to give myself the
opportunity to fold if ten pain Chrissy
goes on and we call and he and we went
so okay so I guess I've been running
pretty good in this tournament there is
a lot of selection bias here right
because I'm gonna I'm not going to like
place your tournament where I get all
another standards right so I mean so
it's in some sense not the best
pedagogical example to use there is a
lot of like selection bias you know that
I'm gonna run very good in the
tournament I choose to show you guys but
I mean if it's between that and you know
having the class be over five minutes is
a classic this is this is the lesser of
two evils all right so so here yeah so
once again this isn't pretty it's not
that big but it's a it's a 17 big blind
shove and once again it's justified by
ICM maybe fold get here Queen seven off
yeah I shove I mean I think it's it's
probably barely a pull I think it's
pretty close it should be be equals
money evey it would be a borderline show
with these smallish entities but given
ICM I know he's less incentivized to
call than usual so all borderline hands
I'm going to be shoving so I do okay so
this hand we get King 10 so once again I
just shove um well once again it's I
think I basically it's hard for them to
call if I just shoved and I am because
if I see a so I'm essentially bullying
him bullying them so when you're the big
stack you can sort of bully people at
the final table because because if I see
him would you get it looked up here
though and we have looked at by a say
and so he he wins I think I'm not gonna
do an exact calculation because I'm
gonna do an exact ICM calculation later
but I would guess his call
I would guess his calls very borderline
I mean it's definitely it's definitely
positive ship expectancy but the fact
that there's this guy 150
7,000 in this time of 70,000 I think I
think it's a call but I think like a six
is definitely full so I think it's
probably one of the weakest hands you
should be calling what I think a state
is probably too good he has to call but
I think it's very borderline in either
case because if I see him so he does
hold though so now so now I see em is a
bit trickier because now we're smaller
we're getting it all in with any of
these guys can really damage us and
there's still like two short stacks that
were kind of everyone is hoping a little
bust soon so you know so in this
situation you know I could like go all
in and believe this pimp accuracy guy
but I see him isn't that relevant like I
can't
he's not gonna fold like East Queen if I
go all in so I just give this one to
them
yeah like calling calling is probably
bad anyway but calling I think is
especially bad because it just increases
the chances of lutely
getting in a bigger pot okay well skip
forward a bit let's see this hand so
East 10 okay so he's 10 off here so this
guy makes it twelve thousand and I guess
I just skipped a bunch of hands but so
Nicholas Brody I think has been very
active and overall I think people have
become very active everyone's playing a
lot of pots so overall I'm gonna put
people on wider ranges than I normally
do but nonetheless here I still full
day's 10 I think it's I think it's East
Jack I would probably get it in and each
ten suited I think I would get it in
it's ten suited is sort of borderline
and once again you know once again
whatever there's sort of when you're
tied between getting in a smaller pot
and getting in a bigger pot you kind of
want to be you want to be folding so
yeah so I guess in the final table I
should make this clear it's not like you
want to fold more it's sort of you want
to go all-in more when you're first to
act but call other people as all-in is
less so that's exactly what's going on
here he's already moved all in and I'm
gonna fold to his all in more often then
normal game but as you can see I'm I
haven't really been tighter in every
sense because when I have to go first
I've been actually going all any more
often and risking it more often because
I know my opponents are highly
incentivized people so anyway so it's so
they go on and I fold here so Nicholas
Brody also folds which I guess is fine
but it's it's definitely a pretty good
Odyssey call there but once again yeah
like I see em just makes it changes
things up a bit
Jack 7 suited once again it's a pretty
big shove but Jack sevens you did plenty
good enough it I see em relevant pocket
nines here we make it twelve thousand on
the on the button so here I think pocket
nines is sort of good enough where I'm
happy at one of them three bases all in
there I call so essentially my strategy
here is I'm going to show like all my
sort of medium strength hands and
especially hands that don't play well
post off like east to offsuit and then
I'm gonna raise small with some of my
hands that are less good preflop the
better post flop let's say like ten
eight suited and also my monster hands
like pocket nines that are also
reasonable to play post flop so so
Nicolas nobody calls here and the flop
is East Jack seven with regards so it's
a bad fall for a hand but it's a good
flop for our range because I I think
given the way the table was going I was
opening a lot and Nicholas Brody is very
aggressive I would guess unless he had
like pocket he says where she might slow
play he would rebase most I was I wasn't
like a hundred percent sure confident
but I was reasonably I'd say like maybe
eighty-five percent confident that if he
had an ace preflop he would have just
went all-in pretty flop so overall I
still say it's a very good flop for my
range cuz I think he's way less likely
to have an ace to me there's a small
chance maybe he he would chicken out
with like east to officers and just call
but I but given how aggressive he's been
I would be surprised if he did that so
so I decided you've been here and I'm
still not sure how good this bed is so I
think at the time
that because of my logic that he can't
it's really hard forever you have a nice
and so I think the best strategy for me
on this flop and in this situation is
just been a hundred percent of my hands
and he's kind of just forced to fold
basically very often because she can't
really keep up with an a second
discontinue betting that being said
though I do think you know if I do
decide as part of my strategy to check
any part of my range here party lines
and light actually be one of the best
possible hands to check back so I think
checking back would have been fine I
guess I've been here because I told
myself I want my strategy to be bet a
hundred percent of my hands which I did
and he fold which is yet which is
reasonably smart because he knows that
you know I can bet again and he's gonna
have to make a decision for all his
chips probably and it's just gonna be
tough okay this hand be my sponsor goes
all-in gets the vines oh yeah sorry why
why don't you say oh um I think it's
basically it's the I think I very rarely
get called by worse and I get called by
everything better like I think she's
always calling a jack and usually
folding a seven like maybe he won't fold
seven eight with some back door drums
but I think he'll usually call a jacket
maybe they'll call seven sometimes but I
still think mostly it's just he'll
basically fold everything that beats me
and call everything that it's just sorry
he'll fold everything that I beat and
call everything that needs me basically
yeah but I saw the side to bed
nonetheless just to win the pot there
and not give him extra outs if he
happens you have like ten or something
so okay so we'll go through this hand so
I'm Hank receive raises he doesn't go
all-in which is kind of curious but um
LP box calls he calls again it's checked
and then LP Marx goes all-in on the
river gym sit down
can you Jack stuff in here yes I guess
so once again Nicholas Brady braces and
then LT marks goes on over him wins a
big pot so I guess I do the same for
Nicholas Brady he's been he's been
grazing a lot so pocket sixes definitely
good enough to risk going all in there
okay this hand if so we get ace Jack
suited and I raised from cut off so I've
been raising fairly to a fairly small
size because the antes are smaller so
that's one thing to remember at a final
table is the pots are actually a bit
smaller because with only five players
the ante the ante the some of the antes
instead of normally being six thousand
is only three thousand in this case so
the big blind has a response to call so
Nicholas Brody goes all-in I look them
up with ace Jack suited definitely good
enough I mean also at this point is
because a number of pots have gotten my
way I'm sort of big enough where even if
I call and lose this I'm still I won't
be chip leader but I'll still have a
decent amount of chips so unfortunately
we lose the AC here so now we're a
second place but we're still doing
reasonably well yeah so you know like I
could have I could have just maybe gone
all in here I mean I guess this guy has
a lot of chips but I could have like
raised to a bigger size you
disincentivize nicolas from me from
doing this with the right wide range of
hands and then sort of like protecting
my stack more from an ICM point of view
but I mean I'm happy with I think
ace Jack suited is just good enough
where I'm happy calling his his all in
which I should have been in this case I
guess yet he sings but yeah okay so Jack
ten suited here so yeah here I just
decided to fold weak I mean we could
consider doing a crazy Bluff all-in but
I don't think this guy's folding that
often they made a rather big rebase
preflop from going three times the
initial
opening so Nicholas Brody goes on here
and they beautiful so Nicholas Brody you
picking up a bunch of chips so he just
takes it down again he's been raising
quite a lot so again a raise and a call
so ok lol p.m. box has been raising over
to other people's Oh
opens quite a lot so he gets called here
but he holds and wins which is
definitely bad news for everyone like
you know if I could have if I would pay
ten thousand chips into the pot you have
this all and build the other way it
almost certainly would be profitable
like the amount I should be willing to
pay to make this all and build the other
way is probably like twenty five
thousand like it's a ridiculous enough
because the just the value of having
people bust and moving up the payouts is
so significant especially when I'm not
such a big stack anymore
okay so now this guy he just doubled up
so yeah so forth so I guess that we were
running pretty good but I say in the
last two or three orbits as you can seen
a lot of things haven't been that
favorable we've lost some all ends and
also people haven't really busted the
chips are sort of just being passed
around the table which is basically not
what you're hoping for
so king 10 off suit we got to walk we
actually go there so walk just means
everyone folds to do in the big blind I
think we've actually gotten quite a lot
of walks at this final table so
something we can keep in mind if we're
trying to play exploitative Lee later
Queen Jack go all in few folds so at 8/7
I guess LPL p.m. box after winning that
so as I sort of noticed the big stacks
are sort of the ones who win most of the
pots and this is sort of expected so
whenever I see em is relevant you would
expect that so although the small stacks
have a hired chef EB then so I have a
higher money eg than chef EB usually
this the ships get transferred from the
small stacks to the big stacks because
the big stacks have more
since to you know go all in first and
sort of bully people around so he takes
this one down next time we get jacks
here so pimp and Christy is actually
kind of short now even though he started
the final table as the chick later
because he's lost a bunch of all ins he
gets it all in here and we hold we hold
against a six so there's actually an
interesting play here I I don't think he
should have done it but this is actually
often a good ICM play so normally I
would say in this situation if you have
a good hand just go all-in because he
knows I'm gonna call so with a sixty
just went all-in but often um there's
this play called the stop-and-go which
is in fact it's not very good like I
don't think it would have been here but
it's an interesting theoretical concept
which is instead of going on he just
called okay he calls and then he
basically blindly goes all-in on the
flop like he I mean she doesn't actually
have to but this is what players used to
do and you can do this in live poker
what you would do in this situation is
you would say call and then before the
dealer even deals the floppy would you
say all-in and this is a legal play and
is essentially to the point is
essentially it's an ICM they'll be the
justification which i think is mostly
wrong but still interesting is he sort
of wants to maximize the chances that I
fold
so essentially okay this is strictly
better right sorry the fact that the
fact that he would call let me see the
flop and then I get to decide whether to
put the remaining chips in sounds like
it should be better for me than me
having to put all the chips in preflop
but the main reason why he does this is
because he doesn't he wants me to have
an opportunity to fold my cards and
avoid getting in a situation where both
of us are playing for all our entire
stack so this was sort of the
justification for it so even though
you're you're giving your opponent more
information
you're also decreasing the chances that
they decide to call to the river card
and have more chances of beating you so
I mean that justification is correct but
it's just that if you crunch the numbers
usually this situation won't be
favorable enough and usually
don't want to be giving your opponent
that extra information okay so so
finally someone busts we get Jackson off
again so he normally I think I would
often consider calling this but I think
just a voice so now this extra sort of
even before the chip leader but not by a
time and I don't really want to get in a
big pot here so I decided to just give
it to him even though normally I would
definitely call this King seven suited I
make a pretty big line for 21 and a half
bets from the small blind and take it
down all right wasn't we'll see if we'll
see all means um so we we full of six
three suited here be my sponsor decided
to raise small which is once again a bit
unusual it usually just want to go all
in a situation where ICM is so relevant
and then Nicolas goes on and he folds
Jack five offsuit here do we fold so
once again this guy raises small so
maybe he doesn't really want to do this
ICM thing and just he wants to play box
he takes that one down though Nicholas
Brody so as you can see it's it's a bit
boring there's not too many hands I I
mean that's sort of what happens when
there's ICM because you people don't you
don't really want to splash around you
kind of just want to survive in the
tournament by risking all your chips
once in a while instead of like slowly
bleeding your tips in a variety of pots
so once again we nine suited big all and
hungie good enough Queen seven suited I
decided to open it raised it up but
unfortunately I guess I mean even if
just one guy went on and I'm clearly
folding so they both go all-in and Ace
King meets Kings which is really bad
news for everyone essentially because if
Kings held then he would have busted but
unfortunately he doesn't so pocket
eights I'm racing here this would have
been a gross spot by the way I think if
it'd be my song sir went on here I don't
know what would have that it would it
would have been very gross because on
one hand I definitely don't want to be
old folding and hand as good as pocket
eights but on the other hand I see him
is just so relevant I think I probably
have to fold so yeah this is a case
where I could have made an extreme like
a very a hero fold essentially a fold in
a very good hand if be my sponsor right
all in so King jack off we get another
lock okay Jack I Jack 10 off um okay
this I'll tell you what happened and
then we'll take a break and then I'll
analyze it after you listen I want to
analyze in a bit more depth because I
was actually surprised going through the
replays looking at how I played this so
LPM box makes it 16,000 and I rearranged
to 44 for 44 um essentially I think this
onion I'm not I don't have a great hand
but I think this is one of the this hand
is too good not to make a bluff with so
that I do that and then he goes all-in
and then I think this is this is a very
tough spot because my hand isn't good
but when i really is i definitely had
the you know if this guy had fewer chips
i would have just went all-in myself I
definitely didn't rearrange the size
thinking I would even consider folding
if he moved on but so yeah the reason I
made this size it so that if this guy
went all-in I could fold but as it turns
out heating people then he went all-in
and then so let's analyze this hand
after the break we'll take like a short
to three minute break okay oh yeah I'll
get started again so get so let's
calculate this hand so I actually
decided to go back and calculate this
hand from an ICM perspective because ICM
is basically very relevant here okay so
let's see exactly how to do this in
practice okay so okay so so okay so
let's first see the chip be be kept the
play shape okay let me pursue that ship
TV calculation so I have okay so uh you
can trust that I copied the numbers
correctly so it's actually there's three
possibilities okay
there's um if I fold this is the
Oh chips this is the amount of chips
I'll have ok so right now I'm only
carrying about chips so if I fold this
is the amount of chips I'll have if I
call in wins this is the amount of chips
I'll have and if I call and lose this is
the amount of chips I'll have so we
could basically do a calculation here
where I do
essentially it's- so let's say my
chances of winning as X so it's x times
so it's x times how many chips I have if
i if i call them lose which is 107 I'm
gonna not write the last three zeroes
plus one minus x times 402 sorry I did
this in Reverse ok X is my chances of
losing so again I'm basically comparing
this number this is how many chips I
have this by full okay and then
essentially I'm just solving for x right
so you so the way I do it is I set these
to be equal and then I calculate X and
that's sort of the break-even X which
tells me what's the minimum equity I
need against his range to call so a so
we can do that so I think it turns out
to be so this formula is equal to the
fold - call / I'm just gonna I did it
okay so okay so I can show these so it's
so essentially it's I had to do one else
right I to do one odds so it makes sense
that I needed a 33% equity you call okay
so how do we give this side so this is
these are essentially the ICM numbers so
essentially the way you complete this is
you Google ICM calculator and then you
just go to the first one it's usually
quite easy to find okay so it's a bit
tricky because you have to put in the
exact payouts so I think at the time
they were like eighteen point five this
this is all as a percentage of the total
pot so I forget exactly the numbers but
it was something like this okay and then
you type in the force you type in the
stack sizes so it takes a bit of time
and you know even if you're fast at this
if you conserve your entire time bank
from the whole tournament for this one
population you probably have enough time
to do it because you're gonna have like
you'll probably have like two or three
minutes of time back saved up so you can
you probably can do it you have to
essentially right so there's three
possibilities I have to calculate if I
fold not only how many chips I have but
how many chips everyone else has and
then I take them in and then I think
that's actually calculate the value of
my stack in terms of as a fraction of
the total money in a pot and then
similarly I do it for the other two
cases and then I calculate the ICM
numbers and roughly speaking this is my
from these are all this is all
normalized
but these are rough this is roughly
midol or EB in each of these three
scenarios and if I do the same if I do
the same calculation I'll find that I
actually 39.6 equity okay so so far does
the calculation make sense to everyone I
didn't do all the steps in practice but
I explain how to do all the steps so
this yeah if you're fast it takes it
still takes like a minute a minute and a
half but the last part is now we have to
open poker state now we have to take
them to Jack ten off C and then we have
to put him on the range so so okay let's
just put him on a Sookie I suspect that
I'm probably gonna have to fold because
39.6%
is quite a lot so I'm gonna put him on
the loosest I'm gonna put him on the
loosest range and see if I have thirty
nine point six so let's say he's pretty
loose so he's going to gamble with let's
say pocket fours plus I mean this
another thing to be that's relevant here
is I think it looks like he doesn't have
full equity like I don't think Wendy's
going on here he suspects that I'm ever
folding or at least he probably thinks
I'm calling him the overwhelming
majority of the time so I think he's
really gonna turn up a stone bluff like
eight seven suited because of this so I
would I would I would be very surprised
if he ever had eight seven suited unless
he would somehow unless he read into
this and realized that I could actually
fold some hands here which maybe he did
I do you shouldn't give them enough
credit so um okay let just do something
somewhat quick let's say he called the
he gets it in with he stayed off suit a
spy suited plus King Jack suited King
Queen off and pocket fours plus so
that's like 14.6% of hands so let's do
this so against this we have we have
thirty six percent equity so that's not
enough we need thirty nine let's see how
wide this range has to be for us we have
39
all right let's say he gets in um
there's 20% of hands which is quite a
lot which is I think way too much 18.6%
of hands oh we actually haven't worse
against this range because her suppose
these it has more hands than dominate us
because I put in a lot of hands like
King 10 and removed a lot of the hands
like a sports
so basically okay you could play with it
however you want but I think it's hard
to play with it in the way to give
yourself 39 percent equity yeah see
we're very optimistic about how wide his
range was so any other case so so at the
time I did fold and it looked weird to
me at first but after analyzing it I
think this is kept playing the right
play if you take into account ICM so I
think it's a good example of ICM because
if you remember like the one we were
playing with it our equity was always
essentially between 33 and 39 like if we
put them on a looser range our equity
would be like 37 and if we put them on a
tighter range our equity would be like
34 but basically it's all it's a
situation where I would always call if I
see him was not relevant and always fold
if I see him was relevant and and this
isn't even the case where it looks like
I see em should be that relevant but I
guess yeah so we do fold so so you know
with hindsight maybe my initial strategy
was wrongly maybe I should have should
not have even plus two maybe I should
have just fold it in the first place
that's that's a different story but
given that I did Bluff I think the best
thing I can do your response okay let me
just jump jump back to the PowerPoint
for
so I just want to talk about a bit more
about this theory of sort of satellites
and going all in the first so if in game
theory this is sort of called the
traffic intersection game so ICM does
not say play tighter it allows you to
play looser if you can go all in first
so this is where it's I actually think
it's very interesting because in
satellites you want to be under the gun
right so normally in poker that's sort
of the worst position because you gotta
act first everyone else gets to act act
after you but in satellites basically
you just want to be the first person to
be able to threat and say look I'm
putting all my chips in you pretty much
have to fold and that's so and
satellites let's say there's 11 people
left and 10 people get a seat if you go
on no one can call you even if they have
aces because if you because you call you
they essentially need to be more than 10
11 sure that they're gonna win the hand
and even if they have populations
they're not going to be 10 11 sir that
they they're gonna win the hand
so basically going Owens first is very
very good it's essentially like it so
it's called the traffic intersection
game because you can imagine the
situation where there's like two cards
trying to pass each other at an
intersection and you sort of want to
save time you pass get there first but
you're worried that the other guy might
crash right you don't yet both players
really want to avoid an accident but
both those players really want to be the
guy to get through first well if you can
act first and if you just tell the guy
look I'm like closing my eyes and tie up
my hands I cannot stop my car okay I'm
just gonna go through the intersection
no matter what right if you're the first
person to be able to do this then the
other guy he's like okay I guess I got
to stop my car now I'm glad you go first
all right that's essentially what it's
like if you're the first person to go
all-in and you already said look I'm
all-in and there's nothing I can do to
take my chips back then the other guys
like all right I guess I'll fold and you
can win the blinds so it's sort of how
it works I mean of course some opponents
are not rational right if you do this
enough times he might fly okay
screw this I'm just gonna kill this guy
right so it's a bit weird and you know
in practice this happens a lot too I
definitely had very bad situations where
you know I'm going on with any two cards
and I know this is a game theoretically
optimal strategy but my opponent is fed
up and then he calls me with like ace
Jack or something and then I have like
Jack to off Susan he looks like a genius
and he beats me when his plays just like
terrible basically oh yeah right so the
snack size doesn't matter yet so I'm
assuming if everyone had the same snack
size in that extreme example where I
said other people should fold aces I'm
assuming everyone has the same success I
guess where's the balance between
knocking you out versus the chip stack I
like the chips differential right right
exactly so so the reason in that case
where it's correctable aces is because
like let's say they call and knock me
out it doesn't help them that much
because first place in a satellite does
not get paid anymore than intense plus
but in real tournaments you'd basically
never hold aces because even if you're
risking losing all your money just first
place will be higher than second place
buy it up and winning with those aces
will increases your chances of coming
first by so much that you should just
gamble anyway but so this is only in
semblance yeah please don't hold aces in
like a normal person
yeah if your shorts back in a sack viola
wanna show two steps and this is going
all-in still makes sense because people
can call you without risking a
tournament right exactly so in that case
you actually need a goodie and you go
online like you actually need to have
positive chip EP as well to go on yeah
so that's why when I see em is relevant
the small stack swing and the big story
the small stacks lose and the big stack
swing because the big stacks have more
license to bully the small sacks around
where is the sauce tax can't ya because
the big stacks and call them more often
and and also does it matter if other
people have like raised behind you it
doesn't just matter who goes all in
first so if someone's already raised
then it's like more likely you going
all-in like it's more likely they're
already committed so that if you go on
they won't fold so so that is relevant
yeah okay right so so so exactly so like
in practice it's very tricky and in fact
it can be beneficial if you can somehow
convince your opponents that you're not
rational
I've never personally done this but I've
heard of people like making a bad call
sometimes in assembly just so people
know inoculate mess of them essentially
good I mean it's it's a bit weird so it
is there's this weird meta game with
this traffic intersection type game
although this is only relevant in like
the most extreme ICL situations which
are like satellites um so I mean I
should say one scenario where I think
you could consider folding aces preflop
in a normal tournament is actually this
so let's say let's say there's 55 and
Tilden let's say 54 get paid and there's
55 left and you got one chip and
everyone else as thousands of chips and
you know that like someone else has
already gotten eliminated that hand so
like if you fold it guarantee to get in
the money then I would definitely fold
aces because even if you win and double
up
congratulations you don't have ten chips
instead of one chip you everyone still
has thousands of chips so and so there
are cases where you could construct an
extreme case where you should fold aces
preflop in a tournament in a normal
tournament as well okay so let's get
back to the tournament now
okay where were we so okay so yeah so we
lost a bunch of chips here but so the
next hand we get we get a king a dog
suit
I raise from the button so we are
committed here I mean it sucks because
our hand sucks but it's way too good
odds to call and I and I see him is
nowhere near that relevant when it's
against the small stack it's the guy
you're trying to eliminate so we call we
get pretty lucky here good good
redemption for that a terrible Jack
tenkan played by me okay
so there's three players left so I see
him is still very relevant we're the
second stack so I were trying not to get
in big on with this guy although it's
less significant because this guy has
still has a decent amount of chips like
if this guy only had 50,000 chips then I
would try a lot harder to avoid getting
in a big pot with me my sponsor
so oops so yeah so he bases and LP and
bucks goes on and takes it down so this
hand he makes it 3x and I decided I
could call here with Queen six suited
which is which is sort of gutsy I think
but I think it's in position and it's
fairly deep and being able to click ICM
pressure on him is reasonable I think it
could have gone either way
I think folding is folding as a holding
as I play the safer play but Queen six
dude it is is plenty good enough here so
I call he just checks um he might just
be giving up on this board where there's
a decent amount of it's fairly variety
right so from what I said last class if
the board is fairly drawing where like
every hand has something if you've got
absolutely nothing then there's not even
much point to make it Bluff like if he's
got east to offsuit here so he just
checks in I bet if he folds so he
probably had like east to officer some
hand like that next time we get a skank
um I decided to race small here once
again so I guess this sort of protects
that Jack 10 him so
I mean you know if I'm doing this with
Jack 10 I do need to get it with do it
with good hands as well to protect the
times that you have Jackson
unfortunately he gets his correctly he
he doesn't hold on I have Jack 10 in
Folsom have a skink so we still take
that one down and we win the blinds the
next hand again so suddenly were were
chipped leader by a decent margin after
those three hands 94 off I'm not gonna
call so sold him so Jackson and so once
again because if I see him this guy just
goes all-in knowing we can't call that
much Jake sit down
seven six offices I decided fold I think
that's very reasonable considering they
can just go all-in on top of that Queen
nine Queen I've gotta walk so one thing
I should pay attention is I do think
these guys but the by now I've sort of
collected enough data points of getting
a lot way more often than I should or I
think these it's not just a coincidence
like I'm constantly confident enough
that they're actually just giving me too
many walks so when they don't give me a
walk I should be I should put them on a
stronger range of hands than I normally
do pocket tens we three bet this guy
again he gets away again so sixty off
see so we've begun built good cards even
though we haven't gotten too much action
from them we're still won a bunch of
chips from getting good cards so Jeff
for off I'm gonna fold you this guy so
as you can see it's fairly boring but I
think this is this is how essentially
what you essentially should happen in
the final final a couple of people left
in the tournament a spin-off so I decide
to so I decided you to not go all in
here I guess that would be 27 big 26 and
a half big blinds which is a bit much so
I decide to just raise small if he three
bets if he realizes to say like 60,000
I'm always going on here and he goes
all-in himself I'm probably I'm
basically not folding even though
it kind of sucks from an ICM point of
view think he's 10 off suit is just way
too good so I'm essentially just raising
small looking for an action here that he
folds 72 off suit we raise enough so OPM
bucks gets a lot Queen 3 off we get
another walk which is nice
Jack five off I I raise here which is
definitely like an exploitative play
it's definitely not you know like
definitely from a Nash equilibrium
optimal play point of view this is
there's no way the optimal strategy is
to raise a fraction of hands so big that
includes jack by bob suit but I think at
the time I probably told myself this guy
was being overly scared even though he
was playing somewhat aggressive earlier
I'm she's maybe is over adjusting for I
see em as being and is respecting me too
much in the presence of this short step
I can look at the HUD stats at the time
although they won't be that accurate
because they're gonna include all the
hands so so that so normally I do play
with all these numbers on so we can see
that his yeah but this is it's gonna be
biased because this includes the hands
with with like six or seven people at
the table but it says that he he calls
from the big blind like only 20% of time
but but I mean that's not a great that's
not that's yeah that's gonna be biased
so it doesn't it doesn't tell this too
much um but I guess at the time I must
have told myself I'm gonna try to
exploit this guy that's the only way I
can see why I decided to raise Jack
fight off suit here so we got a call but
I mean I'm gonna continuation that we do
have a backdoor hard draw and this is
our best chance of just winning the pot
and I could I could maybe barrel on by
barrel I mean bet again as if left on a
bunch of turns so I just bet here he
does fold
next time with Queen 9 we open the
button but we get shoved on and I guess
we have to fold clean 4 we get another
block yeah so this is a feeling
ridiculous it seems like we we literally
gotten like five or six blocks in a row
and I would guess probably we should be
getting a walk like less than less I
guess at a three and a table it's more
often but still less than like thirty
percent of the times yeah maybe I have
been fairly active and but I did fold a
bunch of I didn't fold some water line
situations though like this like this
Jack I think it was a different Jack
seven times yeah maybe that's possible
yeah good point yeah that's good it's
good that word like I'm not complaining
that we're getting a lot and yeah and we
are the big stack so in general you know
it is it is harder for them to bully us
surrounded us to bully them around so it
does make sense from that point of view
to I still thought it was this kind of
too many so anyway so I just continue
trying to raise a lot especially against
this guy so Jackie it offsuit we take it
down jack - maybe we could have folded
but by now this guy was getting short
enough like he's blinded down from 15
and a half big blinds I think just 15
and a half he might have had even more
before like 17 so he might be looking
for a spot to shut down the unites
monster actually bases small here and
get some beef old Jack sticks off here
we got another walk I just skipped the
hands on big blinds
nothing ever happens this way just great
for us
so pocket threes here I just go all-in
so I talked about this before but what
is like what's sort of them okay what's
a problem with my what this play in some
sense
first employ dogs right good so say so
if I don't do this if I just raise small
I have bad reversal five dots right but
the one particular issue sort of is
every other time we've made it twenty
five thousand and really nothing's
changed and suddenly we could we go all
in so it is you know it is a bit
suspicious where he came she basically
knows we have a hand that has very bad
reverse implied odds he basically knows
we have like pocket threes or a spore
offsuit or something like that but it's
still sort of hard for him to exploit
like you know I mean sure you can call
like ace nine and exploit us but I mean
ace nine is already a great hand or you
know you can call the pocket for is an
exploit us but it's not that easy to get
dealt pocket phones order a bit or a
better pair of the pocket fours so so
here yeah even though you know against a
good player he sort of knows my range is
a very small specific number of hands
it's still hard for him do like you
can't really just call Jack ten suited
here maybe he can but probably like Jack
nine suited or queen seven suited you
can't call because it's there's there's
still an off chance we have like three 9
offsuit or something so uh so anyway so
he does fold but it definitely raises
suspicion Jack ten off so Jack's enough
we just go all in here so I think so
this is actually important so but so
normally how you just raise from the
button but by now the big blind has
gotten so sort that I'm willing to just
go all in because the big blind is sort
of sort enough for even if he picks up a
hand and calls and beats me I'm still
the chip leader even if that happens so
the ICM is doesn't hurt me that much
because yeah and also just the fact that
I'm risking less and also not the other
important thing of the big blind getting
short is now the small blind is much
less incentivized to gamble than before
like before it when the big blank had
180 K you know he he was in symptom isin
gamble against me because it's not that
easy to wait for the big blind you bust
but now that the big mine only has ten K
it's easier to sort of just wait and
hope that he busts so basically I see M
becomes
more favorable in both cases and
something I think is very good now with
the Saxons so we do shove and we take it
down 92 off so no one usually wants our
blinds but then they both want our
blinds I'll be unboxing stem so East to
I just go all in here basically same
justification as the pocket threes eats
of it off I think I probably should have
raised this we all in honesty might not
be that bad
I'd have to do an exact calculation but
I think probably I mean it's not it's a
pretty bad hand but I think probably I
shouldn't be folding given that I'm the
big stack and given that they both been
giving me lots of respect but I fold
which can't be a big mistake but I think
probably I shouldn't have folded the
next handout the mbox goes on and we
fold next thing we get 8 7 suited so by
now this guy be my sponsor so we've just
won enough pots where this guy is also
sort of short now so it's a pretty good
situation for us from an ICM perspective
they're both kind of short enough where
we can just go all-in preflop very often
and they have to fold quite often tens
evanov is a bit too weak but I decided
raise but yeah this is a bit
inconsistent play for my part because I
think for most purposes 8:7 off is a
better hand than 10 7 off but for some
reason I raise 10 7 off and fold 8 7 off
these 5 suited we get a walk again
Queen 5 off yeah so I just go all in
here I mean yeah this is so this is
definitely not a plus ship EVD all in
but once again I think I see him by now
is relevant enough where um it's fine
because he just have to fold we see it
down 10 6 off I decided fold big blank
gets a walk get a walk with six deuce
pretty good ace two off once again we
just go on they fold pocket kings Sybase
I
yeah so this is a bit suspicious again
normally I've been going all in you know
he raises small obviously yes five kings
so yeah I mean that's basically true but
I mean also I think I will do this with
some of the weakest hands that I'm not
willing to gamble and with but still
want to raise like maybe like something
like nine seven offsuit maybe but we
take it down so if he goes on we fold
Jack to off suit Queens pursued and go
all-in
so I'm gonna go through this fairly
faster there's a lot of the same same
stuff
six five off we we fold these yeah by
now they're sort of short enough where
they might actually just call us pretty
often so iPhone six five off
so here pocket threes holds against
Queen Jack so that so this isn't so this
is an extreme ICM spot so he calls here
and he does double up so the next hand
we are we do have an extreme ICM spot
because this guy only has one big blind
so essentially the correct strategy is
going to be hein socially shove any two
cards and he's only socially call I
would guess like maybe like the top top
seminary percent of hands in the
situation he normally shouldn't be
calling like tops thirty or something so
I just go all-in and like the FES East
to off suit I'm certain es people like
even if he has like say king queen and I
turn up my hand and show him Jack seven
he probably still has to fold just
because he really can't bust lady yeah I
haven't done the exact math but you know
I wouldn't be that surprised if he told
me like pocket nines is a fold for him I
wouldn't be that surprised so yeah so so
once again I go all-in because this guy
probably can't call so so you do okay so
yeah we went we waiting at ASIC we know
we're just quite it's kind of crazy that
he picked up a nice clean with one big
blinds
some some players like to do do this
thing called like cooperative play to
get the big blind to bust so this is in
the history of poker
it's sort of what was almost customary
for the players in if you have chips in
here to basically just all agree to just
call and not raise each other and to
maximize their chances of busting the
big blind
it's sort of a form of cheating in some
sense it's like collusion in some sense
but it's customary maybe like five six
years ago we're never going to do this
because it sort of benefits everyone
else it sort of benefits all of these
guys if they all agree to do this and it
just maximizes the chances that the big
blind is eliminated but the issue with
this is unfortunately unfortunately
there is an option to be selfish right
unfortunately if you know if we both
trusted each other completely we could
pollute and be like okay we're just
gonna call check down every flop turn
and River no matter what to match so
that we can both see the river with any
two cards and maximize the chances of
busting this guy the issue with this is
you know players when you play a game
you're selfish right and you want to you
know if there is an opportunity to bet
because you have a good hand you're
gonna want to bet more like you know if
there's a draw and you have a good hand
you wanna bet you get the other guy to
fold and basically from a game theoretic
perspective since we have these options
there's no way for us to essentially
agree that we're gonna just check down
and see the river which is why I
consider a collision if players actually
use um so nonetheless I do the I do the
most selfish line which is just go
all-in
but yeah this guy was my best friend and
I wanted to do cheat then I could just
call and let him call and then just
check it down even if I flop the nut
flush but okay so now it's heads up and
so I'll try to show every hand okay so
now I see him doesn't matter but it
would be good to show a bit of heads-up
play because I don't think we've done
too much heads-up play in this class so
we call here and we check he makes it 32
and I decided check raise check raise
bluff this flop I think I think it's
close I mean I think I probably
shouldn't be folding I think Jack's
exuded it just has too many backdoor
draws on this spot to ever fold just as
part of us part of my strategy I think I
decided that I wanted my strategy to to
be I'm gonna raise good hands like
eights and fours and then I'm gonna also
raise hands with lots of backdrops like
Jack's six cards so I decided to do this
so unfortunately he goes all and so we
fold it doesn't quite work so we turn
off me raise Oh so one thing I should
say is I think most of you know this but
once a tournament gets heads up and it's
just the small wine and the big blind
the small blind is actually has position
so normally when it's small line against
big blind a big volume has position
post-flop but when it ends up at a small
line you actually have position so
you're very strongly incentivized to
play in the spotlight it's just by far
the better position because um because
you have position and you'll be put in
less of a blind so another cheat that so
I'm teaching you guys all these
different sheets another cheat that
people used to do it's not really a
cheat but another sort of angle shootin
people used to do back in the day is
there would be people who like normally
play pretty low stakes let's say like 25
cent 50 cent and then they would play
they would sit at these $25 $50 tables
so like where the blinds are play five
bucks 50 bucks which is pretty which is
really high stakes for them and you know
like that it's something they really
don't have the bankroll to gamble all
that but their strategy basically is if
you're the first to sit down you get to
be the dealer on the first hand so the
strategy is basically just um
sit there and then wait for someone else
to sit down and then play the first hand
as the dealer or they have a huge
advantage they ain't just raised and
usually the other guy will fold and
they'll wait fifty bucks
is a huge deal to them and another's
leave after my first hand so this is
something that happened quite a lot and
then so you know my friends and I we
talked about playing a crazy strategy
where you would sit down knowing this is
what the other guy's gonna do and then
sit down with them and you know we would
have the capital to take on risk and
then we would basically just play the
first name extremely aggressively yeah
you don't worry about the guy has to
pull those of the time because if he
calls that's all his money up site so so
yeah it lets do a lot of weird dynamics
but okay so here we have but this is a
turn this is I chose tournaments not
cash gangsters there's fewer ways to do
these commuters cheats so Queen ten we
raise we take it down next time we get
East Queen certain so unfortunately we
go to lock so create we raise we take it
down I started he calls um and then it's
checked to us we continuation bed and he
raises which is weird because it's a
flop that's a lot better for my range
than his because I can have ace king and
his queen and even ace Jack I think if
he had a strategy would it be raised
preflop so in some sense it's weird
because the like it's really hard for
him to have I think pocket aces or
pocket eights or like even pocket threes
he probably would have rebase all-in
preflop so really it's like what do you
have right it's like I don't have much
but really the court it's like what do
you have so it's kind of weird because
you know good I expect him to check
raises flop so really that what he does
on the one hand is just strange but on
the other hand he must know that so it's
you know I'm assuming it's somewhat
balanced and he will occasionally turn
up like h3 or something here so I decide
to call and see one more card I don't
know if that's that's great like maybe I
should have just folded and just
believed him or just like really raised
if I didn't believe him
re-raise essentially as a bluff like
make it like a hundred thousand and two
so he folds but I decide to call the
turn is a nine putting out some straight
draws but no flush draws and he that's
fairly big and I fold I don't really
know how I feel about how he played that
hand I think
I mostly played exploitative li-like I
just called the flop because I wanted to
see what he did and I folded the term
because maybe based based on his bets
sizing or his bad timing I just felt
like he had it so I I'm not sure I'm
extremely happy with how I played that
hand but probably just at the time I
decided to play exploitative Lee and try
to play best against how I expected him
to act so here with ten seven with ten
seven off I decide you'd be base so this
is so the reason I IV raise a hand as
bad as ten send an officer I talked a
bit about this lap two classes ago about
like your preflop raising strategy so
essentially what I'm doing is I want to
be rebasing my good hands and also my
hands
that I'm not sad if he goes all in and I
have to fold and then don't get to see a
flop with so like if I had ten seven
suited that's sort of like too good of a
hand and I really don't want to rebase
and then if he goes all-in fold by
pretty ten seven suited and not even get
to see a flop with it but ten seven
offsuit is a bad enough hand where I'm
not that sad if he just goes on and I
have to fold so that's why I'm raising
like my good hands and also my sort of
weakest possible hands that I that I'm
okay if I don't get to see a flop with
she does call unfortunately but we do
hit a pretty good swap so I'm just going
to bet and get it all in
heads up basically any kind of top pair
is in general just way more than good
enough to put all your money in like
people and stuff so he sips we raise I'm
you know fairly quickly because I'm
running a bit short of time we
continuation bet the flop engine down he
raises here I call with King six which
is pretty borderline not prime how could
I go I mean I think fold it's too good a
hindi fold but probably it's too bad a
hand you call probably I should have
just raised by the same logic as before
but we call and I decided to donk out on
the spot because I figured there's I
mean there's a number of draws I can
have so and here I do sort of have a
weak drawn like a seven gives me a bad
straight but still a very good hand in
that you play clock he calls and the
turn is a jock which I still have a
straight job because now a queen gives
Street so I continued bluffing
it's a hit Gold's just good 62 offsuit I
just give one to them so yeah I think
you should be playing like 90 90 95
percent of buttons and maybe not that
high when it's getting shallower but
like at least 80% of buttons but 2/3 off
suit is one of the hands I'm ok with
folding 8 5 suited I just check raising
the swapping getting it in field so yeah
the same has up you of it you had an
opponent that like from the big blind
was very likely to three bet you yeah
like how would you adjust your range
like opening from the button or the
small one okay so I mean if they're if
they're so if they're really loose you
would basically raise only or like good
hands that you're hoping they raise
along with and so like maybe 60% of your
hands like down maybe or oh yeah yeah
yeah you would you would basically raise
less they just have more value
essentially yeah good yeah yeah and also
another thing you can do is call more I
don't think it gets relevant in this
heads-up match but sometimes it gets
shallow enough where you actually want
to have a calling range pre-thought from
the button okay so Kington so case it
was okay so I do call here I think I
essentially call thinking I would call
if he went on but also just to make it
so that I can also sometimes call a hand
like 10-4 off suit and he can't just
shove any to it expect beautiful
so I said to Collier we got a great spot
so I check it back as a slow play he
checks again on the turn so I bet he
calls the river he leads out quite big
and I just call because I think raising
I'll usually only get called by better
and he actually turns up a fluster so
it's a weird handle but I mean it seems
like we could have lost a lot more but
I'm not saying our opponent played the
hand badly but we were very lucky to
lose this little when we have you know
two pair against a flush and we only
lost essentially like four big blinds or
something I guess I'll be happy to get
away with that okay I'll probably I'll
probably run like
two or three minutes over time I'll try
to bury but I don't want to not finish
the tournament today so we fooled this
maybe I'll skip forward a bit to some of
the bigger pots so what happened here so
we based Jack sticks he goes all in we
fold all right let's go to this one okay
so kings okay so the match has gone in
for a bit if he's won a bunch of pots
he's catching up he's catching up King
three off rebates he calls
so here the flop I think is so once
again it's a situation where I don't
think he ever has an ace so I'm
basically betting a hundred percent he
calls the turns another ace which is a
bad card for us because now it's less
likely we have an ace but so but
normally it's I still think it's a fine
spot to Bluff just because he it's he
essentially can't have an ace and we can
but I think King high is good enough
here where I'm gonna win the pot by
checking it down with my king high often
enough that bluffing is superfluous so I
just check and it struck down and he was
actually trapping with King 9 here so he
wins that one yeah and probably he
wouldn't have folded like let's say I
I bet the turn inch went all-in on the
river probably he has to call just
because it's like almost the best hand
you can possibly have it pretty much is
the best thing you can possibly have
other than maybe like 76 but I think
nothing happens there so let me see okay
so yeah we lose a bunch of pots because
we've raised and he goes he be raises
and we fold so things aren't looking too
good
Oh so I actually made sort of a hero
fold here umm I think once again this is
an exploitative play I would probably
never fold this like from an optimal
strategy point of view I think an ace
and heads up with only 20 big blinds is
way too good but he did just rear ace me
two hands ago and I don't know I think
at the time I just felt like he almost
only had it
did this so I made it exploitative I
made an exploitative fold I'm based on
what I thought he had so the next hand
he raised as we go along the pocket
fives and we heard her a five yeah I was
very surprised I was basically ready to
just leave it I was right in some other
tournaments but I basically was ready to
close the table and focus on the other
tournaments but somehow we get there and
then the tournament just is easy from
there we get a sniper go online he folds
and then he goes on into our pocket
sixes and we hit a straight so we win
all right cool yeah so so okay so yeah
so I played through all the hands in a
tournament once again yeah there's a lot
of selection bias there but hopefully
you learn some stuff from that so
there's two classes left next class all
sort of wrap up the theory is the exact
poker example so talk a bit more about
cash games and show you how to play when
you're like really deep and talk about
like cool spot raising and then Friday
we have a guest lecture from Bill Chang
which should be really exciting he
always have some very interesting stuff
so I'll see you guys around